merci patrick parlons maintenant des
blogs ces fameuses journaux intimes
disponible sur le web un mode
d'expression très prisé par les jeunes
et ils sont créés chaque jour des
dizaines de milliers des journaux tout
genre on peut avoir envie de raconter sa
passion de partager ces moments de joie
mais aussi son mal être un vrai
phénomène de société oui ce reportage de
jennifer albers et georges niankoye à 14
ans léo est fan de jeux vidéo et
d'informatique comme beaucoup d'ados et
comme beaucoup d'ados aujourd'hui léo un
blog un carnet de notes publiées sur
internet
tout le monde peut le lire et faire des
commentaires une nouvelle version des
sites personnels
je mets tes infos soient jeu vidéo que
j'aime bien les films et des fois je me
présente je vais à l'adresse des sites
que j'aime bien des fois je raconte ma
journée je peux exprimer mes sentiments
mes coups de coeur mes coups de coeur
mais certains ados raconte sur ces sites
personnels leurs états d'âme ou leur mal
être de véritables journaux intimes vue
par des centaines de personnes des
anonymes
c'est très important l'anonyme c'est à
dire est ce que en lançant une bouteille
à la mer je vais trouver une âme soeur
peut-être les les canaux virtuels
d'internet peuvent le laisser croire
laisser supposer et d'ailleurs il ya des
échanges autour du fameux blog
mais tout cela est loin de n'être qu'une
histoire d'adolescents 12 millions de
blogueurs dans le monde des dizaines de
milliers de nouveaux blocs chaque jour
parce qu'elle a créé le sien il ya
bientôt un an deux fois par semaine
cette passionnée de cuisine partage ses
expériences culinaires et met en ligne
ses recettes
son bloc est presque devenu une
référence 1200 victor s'y rendent chaque
jour
j'adore cuisiner recevoir mais j'ai
besoin de d'en parler en fait et ce que
j'aime beaucoup c'est le côté
effectivement de donner quelque chose et
en même temps recevoir donc soit des
conseils soient des retours sur des
recettes
c'est une sorte de deux cadeaux
journalier que que je donne et que je
reçois même les hommes politiques et les
chefs d'entreprises s'y mettent
car les blogs c'est très facile et très
rapide a créé sur internet ce qui
explique aussi leur succès deux minutes
montre en main et vous voilà blogueurs
on est dans une société aussi ou le type
de contacts que l'on souhaite c'est
précisément des contacts à distance ces
données et surtout où on garde la
maîtrise donc là c'est typique de cela
c'est à dire qu'on a on se présente à
tout le monde mais on garde la maîtrise
en même temps c'est qu'on peut en tirer
quand on veut loin de l'enfermer le blog
de pascal lui a ouvert un nouvel horizon
elle a attrapé le virus de l'écriture et
elle compte bien aujourd'hui en faire
son métier